well the caucuses are actually being
held Believe It or Not for both parties
tonight where it is Donald Trump one on
the Republican side that was never in
question so even the president's
campaign is focused more on the
Democratic results tonight of course our
Trump is the daughter-in-law of the
president nighted States and is advising
his campaign she joins us tonight from
Iowa Laura thanks so much for coming on
you got it so I imagine if I ask who
would you like to see when you'll say it
doesn't matter because we feel strong
about our chances in November but if no
one was around and I said did you really
like to see win what would you say you
know Bernie looks very strong right now
and I think whenever you're talking
about comparing on November 3rd of 2022
different candidates they couldn't be
more different between Donald Trump and
Bernie Sanders so you're right it
doesn't really matter to us at the Trump
campaign who it is because we really
feel like people are feeling the results
of the Trump presidency in very positive
ways every day across this country so we
feel great as we go into November but
listen if you want to start contrast and
you want to show people really how
frightening it could be out there I
guess Bernie Sanders could be that
person but we'll have to see what the
people of Iowa and all across this
country decide it kind of seems like
Elizabeth Warren has clap maybe that's
too strong and she's collapsed like I
suppose we'll find out fairly soon but
she's certainly not performing in the
way that the national media expected say
three months ago does that surprise you
no I mean listen nothing surprises me
this has been a very unique Democratic
field I think and and obviously my
experience is from 2016 when I was here
in Iowa caucuses for Donald Trump who
did not come in first place so so things
as we know in these very early caucuses
and and primary elections are always
different and you can't really predict
the future by them but it's been a very
interesting field to see and I think
from the Trump campaign perspective
listen we love a clear front-runner so
we can focus in on that person but it
really hasn't panned out that way yet so
it listen we're all watching just like
everybody else in the country to see
what happens it it it does seem awfully
chaotic for a party that has said for
three years now all we care about is
beating Trump that's it I don't care
just give me something that could be
true there's no clear front-runner does
that seem strange to you
well it should be strange the problem is
they instead of focusing on actually
getting along with this president and
doing things positive to impact this
country
they've been obsessed with trying to get
him out of office
so maybe they should have spent their
time I don't know vetting better
candidates and trying to find people
that are likable as candidates instead
they've tried to impeach the president
they've put us forward the rush of
collusion hoax they've worked against
him at every single turn fortunately for
the country the president has been
incredibly successful with everything
he's done despite the fact that they
worked against him so maybe they should
have put their energy elsewhere who
knows yeah I don't think they got
anything out of any of that and of
course as you said the country
definitely didn't lure Trump thanks so
much I appreciate it
you got it thanks so much Tucker